[Música]
sí
disculpa
tendrás cambio de un litro
sobre 20 2007
octubre 20 2018 importante para la
humanidad que casi pasa en anonimato
este día se abrió en la bolsa de nueva
york un índice para especular acerca del
agua y cuando vemos que un millón 200
mil litros de agua cotizaron a 500
dólares probablemente no parezca un
precio demasiado alto para un recurso
sin embargo
cuando nosotros lo transportamos a
aquello que es recomendado para vivir
para sobrevivir 8 vasos de agua
equivalen a un impuesto para la
existencia de 44 76 dólares y sigue
siendo tal vez un monto no considerable
pero si tomamos en cuenta que el 50 por
ciento de la población mundial vive en
áreas urbanas y que para existir en un
área urbana utilizamos alrededor de 31
galones de agua al año pues 2000 dólares
en ese tiempo de vida es bastante
considerable si tomamos en cuenta que
una persona en nuestro continente hace
menos de un dólar al día
y sí
de nuevo conscientes de nuestra huella
hídrica
ponemos esto en contexto de las
actividades humanas la agricultura la
ganadería vamos a ir tomando conciencia
de que 44 dólares para existir es
sumamente
y van a empezar a sonar muchísimas de
las alarmas en nuestra mente acerca del
futuro no de un futuro sobre todo porque
tenemos esta noción no distópica del
futuro en nuestra cultura hay muchísimos
ejemplos de este futuro distópico está
muy bien ubicado en
en muchas películas desde mad max
y todos estos alarmas en nuestra mente
están bien puestas porque podríamos
movernos hacia ese lado pero que hay
no pensemos un momento que requiere la
utopía y aún cuando no tenemos los
ejemplos idílicos de como la tecnología
va a sumar a esa utopía si estamos
conscientes en esas imágenes de ese
futuro idílico de que debemos integrar a
la naturaleza como una parte esencial de
esa arquitectura entonces como no
vivimos en la distopía sino tampoco en
la utopía si no vamos moviendo la
realidad entre ambos yo quiero
invitarlos hoy a que imaginemos cómo
podemos aportar a esa a ese alcance de
ese horizonte como damos el primer paso
para mover ese horizonte utópico no a
través de acciones y bueno para no ir
tan lejos quiero que viajen conmigo como
lo hizo un amigo mío el 2017 me invita a
participar con él en una mesa técnica en
una comunidad en guatemala afuera de la
ciudad de guatemala en la comunidad en
la aldea del fiscal
aquí comunidad ha tomado el poder del
agua
ellos tienen una asociación de vecinos
en donde ellos toman decisiones acerca
del uso del agua y esas decisiones ellos
llamados a la tarea de tomar las
decisiones
de la conservación es decir las
decisiones se toman para foto para
favorecer la disponibilidad de recursos
y esto les ha llevado a tomar mejores
decisiones y estas decisiones han
teniendo rédito a tal punto de que ellos
han hecho inversiones no sólo para
mantener la disponibilidad de recursos
que tienen
agregando digamos de purificación propia
verdad mejores contadores en todos los
casos de los vecinos y estás allí siendo
tan rituales que inclusive las
comunidades alrededor de su propia
comunidad han ido mermando su capacidad
de agua a tal punto que ellos ahora
venden agua a sus comunidades
a las comunidades aledañas y esto les ha
ido ese rédito ha sido tal el éxito de
mantener ese balance bíblico ante lo que
se produce localmente y lo que ellos
consumen de frutas externas para no
socavar su producción de agua que con el
rédito han hecho el salón municipal han
podido construir una una sede de
bomberos de lujo e incluso han podido
dotar de computadoras a las escuelas de
la comunidad todo del buen uso del agua
y entonces nosotros acompañamos a esta
comunidad para entender el balance
hídrico y aplicar ciencia
apliquemos veamos que podemos aplicar de
ciencia a estas decisiones entonces
empezamos a entender cómo es que va el
consumo del agua si no para mapear
exactamente cómo se estaba consumiendo
esta agua y empezamos a aplicar ciertas
matemáticas para saber qué decisiones
sea mejores no a partir de aplicar
ciencia a este consumo de agua a este
conocimiento del agua empezamos entonces
a buscar tecnología no a aplicar la
ciencia de forma automática que tenemos
que desarrollar que debemos desarrollar
para que estas decisiones se han tomado
de forma correcta e implementadas
rápidamente y así que puedan mejorar eso
a través de la información que recaban
pudimos y tienes puntuales por ejemplo
si se pudo perfilar el uso del agua es
decir encontrar aquellos puntos donde
procesos productivos consumían mucho
y esto sólo la distribución sino que
además utilizaron nuevos modelos de
acceso al agua qué quiere decir es que
si yo tengo un proceso productivo de
agua entonces me pueden aplicar una
tarifa diferenciada mientras que puedo
premiar a aquellas personas
sostienen un esfuerzo por llevar un
consumo menor eso fue la primera lo
segundo podemos implicar puntos de fuga
no aquellos puntos donde el agua ya no
ha llegado porque es sí
pero era porque escasea bajo fugas en
las en la redistribución a veces también
pues había fraude de agua no había
personas que pinchaban las líneas de
agua entonces pero entender lo que está
sucediendo en tiempo real a través de la
tecnología esas decisiones que atender
primero qué problemas atender primero
eso redujo muchísimo el desperdicio de
agua y por ende aumentó la
disponibilidad y aumentó las ganancias
sobre el agua
y cuando vamos extendiendo este
entendimiento esta tecnología para
entender y extraer información ya no
solo de dónde se consume de cuánto tengo
disponible sino que le vamos agregando
datos de internet si pronósticos de
lluvia si vamos a tener una buena lluvia
si nuestros pozos no se van a recargar
de forma adecuada
si debo planificar la compra de agua a
futuro toda esta información que ya está
disponible en internet empieza a sumar
más valor a la información que yo estoy
poniendo y por ende mi agua se va
poniendo más valiosa la información
transforma el recurso en un recurso
mucho más valioso verdad y esto es
congruente cuando es el ciclo nuevo del
agua no tenemos agua que su recurso está
agua requiere energía tanto para
distribuirse como para consumirse no
para medirse y eso lo podemos medir la
energía es mucho más fácil de
transformar en información
podemos transformar esta energía en
datos informáticos y esta información
adquiere un valor mucho más grande para
nuestro recurso y entonces tenemos este
ciclo y como les decía el que la
información el valor a un recurso es
algo congruente con lo que está pasando
ahora en otro mundo completamente
distinto no en el mundo financiero
literal entre el dinero ahora es
información lo vamos a ver no y esto
está nuevo este nuevo capital esta nueva
información como moneda puede venir de
muchos lugares puede venir de
información de transacciones como lo es
virtual o puede venir de información de
sensores como lo es y otra son 2 cripto
monedas las cuales la información hace
la moneda
la información ha llegado a sumar tanto
valor que he reconocido como una moneda
per se y entonces nosotros podemos
fácilmente ver que este protocolo en
toda información se está uniendo cada
vez más a las leyes del mercado de la
economía porque ahora estamos hablando
de que la información es moneda entonces
vamos a encontrar coincidencias en que
en cuanto más tenga disponibilidad de
una moneda obviamente su valor tiende a
bajar y tiende a depreciarse si hay
demasiada disponibilidad dentro de estos
protocolos se han implementado en
algunos no algunas por así decir la
deuda es práctica que ya economía que
armón a quemar moneda manera de revaluar
la moneda circulante
y estos toques que están circulando si
aplican algoritmos de qué.es
y precisamente lo que se hace con ese
algoritmo de quema de tokens es
revalorizar los tokens spray puestos y
como hacemos ese puente mental entre
bueno si la información es moneda y
tenemos una forma real pisar nuestra
información así como hacemos
conservación se vuelva así importante
como saber si agua inteligente es
información como la parte mos tan
importante como una moneda entonces
podemos ver que en teoría esta empresa
si podría invertir en una cartera o yate
en una inversión
estas cripto monedas y a través de
cortar nuestros sensores inteligentes a
internet que proveen parte de esa agua
una empresa sí que tiene inversiones en
cripto moneda en esta nueva economía
podría agarrar parte de su de sus toques
para revalorizar el resto de sus
toppings y hacer una donación de agua a
través de un pozo inteligente
mientras que ellos consiguen el rédito
de valorizar lo en la moneda que aún
tienen esto sería hecho de forma
transparente para ellos ellos podrían
literalmente escoger en qué lugar del
mundo quieren brillar cuánto de agua sí
y podrían ver en qué fecha sucedió y a
quienes directamente impactaron y
beneficiar dando así muchos de los
problemas no de transparencia a la hora
de hacer donaciones a la hora de tener
programas de responsabilidad empresarial
y entonces esto nos lleva a considerar
que en el futuro quizás esto sea un
primer paso
uno en el cual la conservación de
nuestro recurso ese uso inteligente de
nuestro recurso común natural sea tan
importante como conservar el valor de
nuestro dinero
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y